in this video I'll demonstrate my
process for creating a spec title
sequence that is inspired by the
yellowjacket's titles
[Music]
hi my name is Cameron and I'm the
creator of motion science before we get
started I want to invite you to join my
motion design workshop at
motionscience.tv Workshop where I unveil
my personal techniques and hidden gems
that I use in my daily workflows this is
a free workshop and takes about 30
minutes don't miss out on this chance to
level up your skills and make sure to
visit
motionscience.tv Workshop after watching
this video you will not regret it in
this video I'll demonstrate my method
for creating a spec title sequence if
you're interested in working in title
design creating a spec title sequence
for your reel is one way of quickly
breaking into the industry this
particular title sequence was inspired
by the Yellowjackets titles if you
haven't seen them yet definitely check
them out my first step in creating the
title sequence is selecting the footage
for a real world title sequence the
studio would most likely provide the
footage or you would be tasked with
filming the footage but when building
out spec work I can use suitable stock
footage I use art grid to search for
keywords such as mystery murder and
weird I play around with different
keywords to find the right striking
shots for my project I next head over to
epidemic sound to find a music track
that will drive the feeling in the pace
of my edit I don't spend a lot of time
searching for music again I enter
keywords into the search bar and Branch
off from there the key here is to give
myself creative limits like time if I
don't limit my time searching for assets
I can end up spending hours or even days
looking for elements I download several
footage and music options to work with
and I import them into Premiere Pro I
drag and drop the different music tracks
on the timeline and I focus on finding
the right Vibe when matched with a
visual again I don't spend a lot of time
doing this as soon as the music track
strikes me as interesting I select the
remix tool and remix the music to my
desired length when creating spec work
for my reel it's not necessary to create
really long pieces either because if you
think about it pieces on a reel are
generally just a few seconds long now I
start the editing process I spend an
hour or two dragging and dropping shots
of the music I rearrange the clips I
experiment with in and out points and I
have fun with this process because
what's the point in creating spec work
if you're not enjoying the process if
you're not learning and if you're not
having fun even though there was no real
story to this title sequence because
this show doesn't actually even exist
I'm focusing on telling a visual story
of some kind the visual story doesn't
have to make sense it just needs to flow
visually once I have the footage in
place I then send the sequence of
footage into After Effects through Adobe
Dynamic link I replaced the timeline in
Premiere Pro with an After Effects
composition this process is simple and
it sends the Premiere Pro edit directly
over to After Effects Pro tip I quickly
jump back into Premiere Pro at this
point and I undo the last step the
reason I undo this Dynamic Link in
Premier Pro is because if I ever need to
fine tune the edit back in Premiere I
can still do so without having to edit
in After Effects the timeline in
Premiere is still the individual clips
now back in After Effects I start to
layer in VHS and analog tape noise I
layer this textured footage at the top
of my timeline to add visual interest
over the existing shots I also have a
package of VHS effects from AE juice
that also help to add more texture and
more visual interest I'm going to link
these VHS Textures in the description
below if you're interested in picking
them up at a great price I experiment
with different video looks and signal
distortions until I start to get
something that piques my interest I love
to layer effects and textures and build
up looks I try things that work and I
try things that don't work the thought
process behind this is to experiment and
look for those happy accidents these are
those moments where you say to yourself
yep that looks really cool I can't
stress enough here that having fun is so
key it's so important to enjoy the
process now the look is starting to come
together so I switch gears to focus on
color adjustments it's important that
each of these clips fits together in the
sequence I want the cliffs to all look
like they were shot together so I used
some color correction effects like
curves tent and CC toner I always prefer
to go simpler routes When developing
looks and these effects are simple tools
that lead to good results for this
project I experiment with color palettes
and I find that blue and green are
working quite well next up is type
layout as a motion designer you only
need a handful of typefaces in your tool
kit and one of my favorites is Den for
this project it will work now with the
type sitting below the effect adjustment
layers the effects are way too heavy on
the type and make it challenging to read
so I decide to relayer the type above
the adjustment layers now the type is a
little too perfect looking sitting at
the top of the layer stack so here's a
pro tip for you add a very small amount
of blur to the tie to help him look more
organic usually this is a very small
amount of blur under a few pixels and in
this case because the type is so small
the amount of blur is below one pixel
it's a subtle change but it's all in the
details I create a few more moments of
type using made up names and I position
the type using the rule of thirds using
the rule of thirds helps to give my
composition balance to enhance the
overall look of the composition and give
it that last extra bit of finesse I add
one more adjustment layer towards the
top and to this layer I add the red
giant analog effect this gives the title
sequence that extra bit of a CRT look
that I had envisioned lastly I will make
the final color adjustments to any clip
that I find isn't quite working within
the sequence this is that last 10
adjustment that is critical in
developing professional quality motion
design and there you have it my process
for creating spec title work for my reel
that is inspired by the yellow jackets
titles because this is my own spec
project I can create whatever I want to
see this is the work that creatively
fulfills me maybe someone else will see
this piece am I real and be inspired or
even better maybe someone else will see
the project and hire me or pay me to
create something very similar I really
hope you enjoyed the video and found it
both informative and entertaining if you
did could you do me a huge favor and hit
that like button also if you want to see
more content just like this in the
future consider subscribing to my
YouTube channel your support means
everything to me and it really helps me
to keep creating more great videos for
you I would love to hear your thoughts
on the video so please leave a comment
or question below as always thanks for
tuning in and I can't wait to connect
with you in the next video
foreign
[Music]